now labour politicians have reacted uh
pretty angrily for example uh kate green
the shadow education secretary uh has
said that uh
um
uh kate green has said uh it's insulting
and shocking our country and our
children deserve better uh david lammy
in the shadow cabinet says uh
to miss on twitter you must be the most
ignorant clueless and incapable
education secretary in the uk's history
in the lib dem spokesman daisy cooper
says it's shocking and embarrassing and
it should be the final nail in the
coffin for mr williamson being a member
of the government of course this all
comes with mr williamson top of
everyone's list uh for uh demotion or
the sack in uh
possibly uh potentially in imminent uh
cabinet reshuffle so what has happened
here clearly is that uh mr williamson
has blundered he has mixed up two
high-profile sportsmen who are also a
very successful and high profile
political campaigners marcus rashford on
school meals education
and uh
and maro italji who is a
top england rugby player played with the
lions uh in the tour that's uh
just finished a few weeks ago tiptoes
that's him in the lion's shirt tipped as
a future england rugby captain
um marcus rashford of course plays for
manchester united and
is an england international is currently
uh injured well the uh two sportsmen uh
whilst the politicians are getting very
hot under the collar about it the two
sportsmen
seem to find the whole thing slightly
amusing uh this was a tweet from marcus
uh rashford uh responding to a
journalist's uh tweet uh there it is um
accent could have been a giveaway uh he
uh he he has tweeted and uh the rugby
player maro itaji has also tweeted in
the last few minutes uh he has uh said
this uh due to recent speculation i
thought it was necessary to confirm i am
not marcus rashford while we are here my
name is not mario either and a simple
marrow itaji uh will do much love mark i
mean
so he's obviously seen the funny side of
it now i can bring you a response uh
from gavin williamson because in the
last few
minutes he has issued a statement in
which he says this
towards the end of a wide-ranging
interview in which i talked about both
the laptops and school meals campaigns i
conflated the issues and made a genuine
mistake we corrected this with the
journalists before publication of the
story he goes on to say i have huge
respect for both marcus rashford and
maro italy who run effective and
inspiring campaigns well
turns out mr williamson did meet mario
todgy but not marcus rashford
and obviously he tried to
correct the mistake as he said in his
statement um
the uh marcus uh rashford spokesman has
told sky news that he's written two
letters to mr williamson i received a
cold response uh to one uh a copy and
paste of an in a wikipedia page uh he
wrote about another write another letter
marcus is asking those empowered for
collaboration more often than not this
ask is rebuffed marrow and marcus are
two incredibly successful young black
men but there is more there's little
more they have in common uh whether it's
daniel rashford now that is a reference
to a blunder made by matt hancock when
he was health secretary got mr marcus
rashford's name wrong or a a marrow
itoji reference the message remains the
same put our children first well all
this in the week of talk of a reshuffle
in prime minister's questions it should
be said boris johnson defended gavin
williamson uh asked a question by the
labour school spokesman peter kyle
mr kyle said put hand on heart is he the
right person for the job is he up to the
job uh the pm said the education
secretary has done a heroic job of
dealing with a very difficult
circumstance in which he we have had to
close schools during the pandemic note
the use of uh has done a terrific job
there is other reference that perhaps mr
williamson is for the chop in the
reshuffle well uh he's certainly
on the receiving end of
a bit of a defeat here uh i said earlier
uh sportsman one ma sportsman one uh mr
williamson nil i think it's two nil to
the sportsman now don't you now that uh
uh marrow itoji has also uh hit out
albeit in a very humorous way